there's a waitress who's gone viral on
Tik Tok for complaining that she doesn't
make
$200,000 a year despite the fact that
she has a bachelor's degree in Business
Marketing I have a bone to pick with
America so I'm headed to my serving
job I hate
it I hate it why I make more money
serving I have my literal business
marketing
degree that put me in a
cute $80,000 in
debt and I make more serving sushi rolls
cuz I was I've been applying to
marketing jobs for weeks now and the the
pay cut is
insane insane but the jobs that are like
a c 150 to 200,000 a year I'm not
getting those I'm a 20 almost 25
5-year-old my birthday soon almost
25-year-old chick going against you know
corporate ass America people with so
much experience all I got is my degree
you know people say get your degree but
then they don't talk about how you need
experience the degree was the
experience I need
relax the degree was not the experience
I I pity her I I don't pity the extreme
entitlement
this woman is saying hey I'm a
25-year-old chick I don't have any
experience really in anything and I need
to make $200,000 a year because I got
some almost certainly meaningless degree
and I took out some debt and I made poor
financial decisions and but the culture
encouraged me to make those poor
financial decisions but I'm 25 years old
and I want to make 200 Grand did you
make 200 Grand at 25 years old did you
if you're listening to this show right
now
have you made 200 Grand ever have the
vast majority of people ever made
$200,000 let alone at
what planet is this woman living on
where she thinks that is something that
I suppose that's something to shoot for
later on in your career if you're
willing to put in some hard work it but
where you think you're just entitled to
200 that's a lot of money and you're 25
no 25 unless you're working on Wall
Street or in a handful of very very high
paying jobs no 25-year-old makes that
and she makes an observation here that
she thinks is an indictment of our
economic system but it's not actually
she she is ironically undermining her
point when she says I can make more
money waiting tables than I can pursuing
my career we'll get to that in one
second because we do have to talk about
that but first when you want to talk to
your friends you need to check out peer
talk right now go to peer talk.com last
week peer talk announced they would
alleviate $10 million in veteran debt by
Veterans Day how by giving a portion of
every new order to this cause thanks to
your support P talk is 27% to their goal
with three weeks to go our veterans gave
everything to protect our great nation P
talk understands the sacrifices they
have made when you switch to peer Talk's
Lightning Fast 5G Network they will
donate a portion of every new order to
this noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell phone service peer Talk's plans
start at just 20 bucks a month offering
unlimited talk text more data and a
mobile hotspot just go to Pur talk.com
nscw and make the switch let's rally
together show our unwavering support for
our veterans and also support this
excellent company which is going to give
you the best cell phone service out
there at a fraction of the price Pur
talk.com nscw switch to Pur talk today
it is the right move it is the American
way Pur talk.com slns right now go to
goodranchers use code nolles every
Halloween you hear about the dangers in
the candy that your kids will get but
this year the real tricks are in the
meat aisle good ranchers wants to take
the trick out of your meat and they're
throwing in a treat for my listeners for
30 bucks off your order with promo code
NES kwg goodranchers.com I got a new
order of good ranchers yesterday you
know I love good good ranchers it's one
of the least favorite things I have
about going on the road is I have to
miss eating my delicious just good
ranchers so I get the steaks and I get
the ground beef and the burgers are the
greatest ever and I get the beautiful
chicken and everything and you know what
they threw in pumpkin spice bacon and
you know what's even more amazing about
this Alisa hates flavors added to Meats
because she thinks it's usually going to
be some kind of artificial terrible
thing that's going to you know turn the
frogs gay or whatever but the way that
they did this with the pumpkin spiced
bacon it is so natural it is so like all
of their it's just the best in the
business they got theow lowest prices
it's if if you're not ordering good
ranches right now I don't know that I
can possibly help you text code nolles
kwes for 30 bucks off your box today the
box of America's best meat and seafood
30 bucks off goodranchers.com American
Meat delivered she can make more money
waiting tables that's true you you can
make relatively decent money waiting
tables have waited tables probably many
of you who are listening to this right
now have waited tabl tables you
can the downside of waiting tables is
there's not necessarily a ton of job
growth there can be if you really want
to dig into the restaurant business and
then I don't know become a head waiter
become a manager who knows open a
restaurant like there there are paths
for growth but generally speaking if you
are just going to be a waiter then you
can make relatively decent money
depending on the restaurant depending on
the clients but there's going to be a
ceiling there this woman wants to blow
pass that ceiling she wants to make
$200,000 a year but if you want to make
$200,000 a year you got to do a lot of
grunt work first before you can get on
that path you don't get some of the
benefits of just having a job if you
want to have this
more risky and ambitious kind of
career in my first jobs in politics my
very first job in politics I made I did
the math I I received a monthly stipend
I was a teenager I made 75 cents an hour
that was my first job it was a campaign
job in politics and then one time while
working for the campaign I got a
speeding ticket for 300 bucks so that
reduced my earnings to like 50 cents an
hour I think about my first jobs in the
media I'm sure I wasn't paid anything
and even when I was paid something it
was very Hit or
Miss if you if you want to have a career
one of these things that's a little
tougher to find and that involves more
risk you're going to have to do a lot of
grunt work work now the the mistake here
is this woman went way into debt to get
a degree that is meaningless no
undergraduate Business Degree in my
estimation is worth $80,000 because it's
not experienced and the employers don't
view that as experience and you're going
to learn a lot more with on the job
training I'm a I'm a the last
conservative I think one of the last
conservatives who promotes University
education but only in certain
circumstances at certain universities
and spefic specifically if you're
studying something that will not
directly get you a job I think the point
of it is to study Dusty old books and to
read old philosophers and Poets and
historians you can do that better at a
university than you can other places on
your own on YouTube sitting around in a
bull session somewhere universities are
still in some way is better at doing
that than other places no University is
better at teaching you business
marketing than than a company is a
company is always going to be better at
that and This Woman's just been duped
and so she's 50 she's 80 grand in the
hole and she's been fed a pack of lies
that if she goes to Palookaville
University and gives them a bunch of
money she'll get some piece of paper
that's going to give her a bazillion
dollars and that's just not true but if
she is ambitious if she's really
ambitious then she will give up the
waitering job and she will accept the
lower pay in the short term for bigger
payoffs in the long term this is the
political issue here and you see it at
the personal level and you see it at the
political we as a country used to be
willing to defer gratification you think
of the pilgrims who came over here in
1620 they deferred comfort for their
whole lives they really never had any
and they just worked very hard with that
Pilgrim Puritan work ethic and over time
they built up a prosperous country and
now we get to enjoy the fruits of that
and we hope that we can pass that on to
our children
I don't think we think that way anymore
we just want the short-term profit we
want the quick money we don't think
about the future we don't have children
and when we do have children The
Inheritance that we leave them is a
mountain of debt boy what a great clip
that was
now ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see you
next time